[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand l'invention au droit chemin nous
parvenions à la lumière qu'il est s'est
elle jamais
par le christ notre seigneur
[Musique]
on rencontre le christ nous appelle pas
le téléphone mais il ya des moments où
on ressent une présence
au séminaire durant les six ans de
formation on doit faire deux fois sa
valise sinon on est peut-être passé à
côté
est-ce que
c'est après que je pense que tu vois ce
que simplement 7 à présent c'est pas un
appel toutefois se vivre autrement une
autre forme de vie chrétienne
si notre monde évolue sans cesse
celui du séminariste reste immuable
avant même le lever du soleil les
pensées sont toujours tournés vers le
ciel
[Musique]
cette année notre dame de l'espérance
compte une quarantaine de séminaristes
aux côtés des français des étrangers
envoyés par leur diocèse d'afrique ou
d'asie du sud est mais ici ne parlez pas
de collègues
comme des frères plus comme des frères
même si on n'est pas lié par le son qui
sont quand même eux liés par le custom
la naissance amira
a déjà nous entend pas ce que l'on vit
dans une communauté et c'est une
communauté des frères endroit le fait de
vivre au jour le jour une bonne et saine
au séminaire la formation spirituelle
rythment la journée prière des laudes à
7h30 des vêpres à 19 heures et bien sûr
la messe du midi celle de l'eucharistie
le car ici c'est vraiment le centre de
notre journée pour nous ce pain et le
vin c'est vraiment le corps et le sang
du christ voilà qui chaque jour les
offres s'offre pour nous dans le
sacrement de l'eucharistie
florent et rentrer au séminaire à 20 ans
aujourd'hui en quatrième année il espère
être ordonné prêtre à la fin de sa
formation au diocèse de nevers
au moins un prêtre c'est quelqu'un qui
est à l'extérieur qui va vers les gens
et qui au plus proche des gens et le
pape françois nous nous le dit au tout
début de son pontificat il a dit voilà
je voudrais que les prêtres et l'odeur
des brebis ouais parce qu on donne cette
image du prêtre comme pasteur comme
berger d'un peuple oui mais il faut pour
avoir l'honneur des brebis je dirais il
faut être en contact avec eux il faut
discuter avec les gens m
[Musique]
il y a
[Applaudissements]
le séminaire s'est un peu l'université
avec dieu ou paco le film cours de grec
de l'atteindre droit canonique les
étudiants suivent une dizaine de matière
sur les six années de formation
[Musique]
car pour devenir prêtre il ne suffit pas
de prier tous les jours il faut avoir
une formation intellectuelle solide
essentiel de d'approfondir la foi de
l'église la foi des chrétiens la lecture
de la bible évidemment comment est ce
qu'on lit la bible qu'est ce qu'on y
trouve qu'est ce que ça nous dit puisque
derrière on sera à nous appeler à avoir
une dimension presque d'enseignants en
5e année
foucault est à 26 ans l'un des plus
anciens élèves du séminaire dans
quelques mois
s'il en a toujours l'envi et si l'église
le juge ap il sera ordonné prêtre chez
lui dans le diocèse de moulins
quant au futur sa voie est toute tracée
car lorsqu'on est prêtre pas besoin de
cv
[Musique]
fait de devenir prêtre c'est un appel
ctrc c'est dieu qui je crois m'a appelée
à devenir prêtre et si l'église aussi
qu'ils m'appellent à devenir prêtre et
c'est pareil pour tous les postes dans
l'église c'est toujours un appel c'est
dire c'est toujours reçu n'ya pas de
candidature je ne candidats pas pour
devenir évêque jeune candidate pas pour
devenir pape sait on vient me chercher
en usant ben voilà on a besoin de toi là
donc on ne fait pas de plan de carrière
la grande majorité des séminaristes et
destiné à retourner dans son diocèse
d'origine
mais certaines congrégations religieuses
forme des prêtres missionnaires c'est le
cas de mme anne chimie il a 25 ans et il
est originaire d'haïti
en entrant dans cette convocation
missionnaire donc jean travers ce
mouvement d'être
de devenir missionnaire est la
particularité de cette convocation c'est
qu'on n'est pas prêts dans sa terre
natale mais on est prêtes ailleurs de sa
terre natale ce qui fait que j'ai
intégré le mouvement en fait j'ai
accepté cette manière c'est une façon
d'être pointe parmi d'autres
lorsqu'on rentre au séminaire on est
tout de suite plongé dans le grand bain
recevoir le christ s'accompagne aussi
d'un certain nombre de renoncement je
pense qu'il ya un petit côté tard et
parce que évidemment c'est
incompréhensible
et je le conçois coup parfaitement c'est
incompréhensible pour le monde le choix
que je fais
effectivement un voeu de pauvreté de non
réussite sociale ça c'est assez clair je
ne cherche pas la réussite sociale voeu
de célibat aussi qu' évidemment et ne
rentre pas dans les cadres sociaux de
notre époque donc il faut un petit grain
de folie mais
mais on le on n'est pas le seul à le
faire on est plusieurs à le faire et on
s'entraide et puis on sait pourquoi on
le fait aussi et si évidemment on
n'avait pas la fois on le ferait pas
c'est ça qui est difficile à comprendre
pourtant les femmes ne sont pas
totalement absente dans la vie de ces
ouvriers de l'évangile le séminaire
d'orléans fonctionnent grâce un certain
nombre de laïcs des personnes
extérieures au clergé comme les
bibliothécaires les professeurs ou la
secrétaire
dans tout environnement il faut les deux
chaque personne apporte sa personnalité
que ce soit féminine masculine de toute
façon les prêtres y seront loués à prêts
à travailler avec eux des laïcs quand
ils seront prêtre aujourd'hui l'église
essaye de justement de rassembler aussi
bien les laïcs que les que les prêtres
et donc il faut leur apprendre à vivre
avec des laïcs c'est indispensable
vivre avec des laïcs mais aussi bien
vivre ensemble le séminaire est aussi un
internat alors les tâches collectives
sont prises au sérieux
c'est aussi dans le cadre de la
formation à prendre pas plus tard on
sera dans un presbytère et se dire que
ce sera à nous d'entretenir notre
logement et d'entretenir aussi l'accueil
des gens ici dans la maison on accueille
aussi des groupes extérieurs
du diocèse d'orléans donc quand on
accueille les gens c'est quand même
agréable d'avoir des savoirs de le voir
on peut même voir son visage par
tysabri la vie de ces années c'est juste
essentiellement baer plier mon j'ai
étudié en fait compte non pas on assez
cette ville à cette vie cachée que
personne ne le connaît
on fait nos tâches communautairement des
temps en temps on a des petits plaisirs
comme le mercredi après midi dans la
cuve en football
est comme un esprit sens épanoui dans un
corps sain nos futurs prêtres n'hésite
pas à transpirer
ça permet de sortir un peu du cadre de
la journée de respirer autrement quoi et
puis ça fait plaisir d'être avec les
autres aussi pour se détendre dans un
autre cadre et dans cette drôle de vie
faite de rigueur et de discipline
la musique profane s'invite aussi
certains soirs parfois pour le pire
souvent pour le meilleur
sortie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toute façon on n'avait pas de bol parce
que moi j'ai réunion téléphonique
mais le mercredi il y a que vous qui
faites rien
ici le patron c'est dieu et son adjoint
le père laurent tournier recteur du
séminaire depuis une dizaine d'années
l'accent est mis sur l'accompagnement
psychologique notamment sur les
questions de célibat et d'abstinence
pour tout ce qui touche à l'affectivité
une question qui reprises quatre fois à
peu près à différents moments de
l'information des passages clés pour les
ré interpeller les ré interroger pour
que chacun puisse être dans l'honnêteté
où j'en suis comment je le vis comme je
me l'assument comment je commence à être
dans une durée pour leur donner
l'habitude qu'en fait cette question
n'est jamais réglé quelles que soient
les vocations le rapport à la sexualité
il évolue mais à tous les âges de la vie
et donc il faut que pour un prêtre ce
sera la même chose et je crois que ça
c'est quelque chose qui est important et
ce a redit combien la formation dans
l'église comme ailleurs doit être une
formation permanente
près de 80% des séminaristes de notre
dame de l'espérance à moins de 30 ans
pour la plupart la vocation est venu
vers 20 ans
qui est fort dans la vie au séminaire
c'est la vie communautaire et les liens
qu'on tisse entre nous on vit dans une
même maison on vit les mêmes choses les
mêmes doutes aussi les mêmes questions
les mêmes joies
donc je crois que ces liens là resteront
et puis évidemment toute la formation
qu'on reçoit qui est vraiment très riche
moi je crois qu'au séminaire j'ai appris
à devenir un homme j'ai pas appris à
devenir un prêtre voilà aussi bien sûr
j'espère mais j'ai d'abord appris à
devenir un homme à grandir en maturité
je me connais mieux aujourd'hui je
connais mes limites mes qualités et je
crois que ça c'est essentiel et j'aime
bien dire d'ailleurs que je pense que
tout le monde devrait faire un séminaire
[Musique]
ceux ci vers l remplir l'aide de barques
à tel point qu'elles en font c'est
le jour du seigneur et déjà un jour
travailler pour ces jeunes séminaristes
en contact avec les fidèles comme une
répétition avant leur ordination
le costume
est ce que vous sentez prêt pour la
faire cette messe près pour célébrer la
messe on n'est jamais prêt
mais et on s'y prépare progressivement
et puis on s'approche cette échéance
mais c'est toujours un peu
impressionnant c'est à dire qu'un jour
on sera passera de l'autre côté
oui c'est toujours un peu impressionnant
je pense pas qu'on soit un jour près
vraiment ça impressionne toujours j'ai
envie dirait
il viendra un soir comme on la chante
sauveront séminaire donc voilà un jour
peut-être et en essonne dans l'espérance
voilà et un jour lorsque le moment sera
venu on sera derrière mais pour
l'instant de se former
la plupart d'entre eux sera ordonné
prêtre en moins de deux ans jeunes
d'origines diverses et mieux formés ces
sommes sont les futurs visage d'une
institution qui compte sur eux pour
faire face aux défis à venir
[Musique]
à
or aidants
moreno